Okay. For homework two, we asked you to modify
the interpret function so that JavaScript elements are
– the output of the JavaScript reinterpreted and run
through the HTML interpreter. So instead of just
basic JavaScript output, we can actually output
further HTML making our JavaScript quite a bit more powerful.
So how do we change this, so that we can do that?
Well, first off we can see that we’re not really
concerned with these two branches of this if statement.
We’re not concerned with word elements or tag
elements, we care about JavaScript elements. So we
already know that we don’t really need to
do anything right in here. We need to do
something to modify how we interpret JavaScript.
So we go down here and the two lines I added are
right here. Now instead of just outputting the results
of the JavaScript interpreter’s abstract syntax tree
output. What I’m doing is I’m running the result of
the JavaScript interpreter back through the HTML
parser, the parse function. And outputting that
abstract syntax for you, which this is HTML now and
then we run that back through this function itself so
that we can further interpret the syntax tree. Now
after we’ve done that, we don’t really need this last
graphics doubt word resolved. We don’t need to
further interpret result. We’ve already done that. So
we can just get rid of this and to check whether this
works, we click run and we see below that we do
indeed get our page output, but okay. So we’ve got
this JavaScript output, but you can see that the odd
numbers are bold and the even numbers are italicized
which if you check, the web page that we gave you as
an example, is exactly what we’ve done. We’ve
wrapped the even and odd numbers or the odd and
even numbers respectively in bold and italic text,
which is what you see down here. So this gives us a
lot more power in our JavaScript interpreter because
we can use our JavaScript to now output
further HTML that we can run on the fly.
And that is going to be very, very important.